[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
locales et régionales de la tnt tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité
c'est un endroit peu connue des
habitants il regorge pourtant de
richesse documentaire et v60 18 nous
emmènera dès le début de ce journal dans
les entrailles des archives
départementales les yvelines et
documents historiques s'y trouvent et
ils sont accessibles à tous vous allez
voir les livres de l'été guillaume gonna
sera l'invité de cette édition il est le
seul auteur français avoir retracé la
vie et le parcours de robert kennedy le
frère cadet de l'ancien président
américain qui fut ministre de la justice
de son pays un frère éminemment
important dans la vie politique des
états unis et puis des images
magnifiques aussi venu de corse où vous
le verrez il est possible de visiter
l'île à cheval il balade en bord de mer
et dans les traverses rocailleuse des
images de via télé pas aisé sur place
c'est un lieu méconnu mais essentiel
pour la mémoire de nos territoires les
archives départementales sont présentes
dans chacune des collectivités éponyme
de france dans les yvelines les
documents s'accumulent sur 32 km mais
alors quelles sont les missions de ce
service public qui trouve-t-on
concrètement les réponses dans ce
reportage de justin brasier pour tv 78
dans les yvelines donc
ici 32 km de documents sont conservés
dans des conditions spécifiques créés en
1794 les archives départementales sont
implantés à montigny le bretonneux un
service public méconnu ouvert à tous
objectifs de la structure collecter les
archives identifier et classer les fonds
et bien sûr les mettre à disposition la
structure conserve l'histoire du
département au moment de la révolution
française ont été collectées et
conservées rassemblé d'anciens titres de
propriété des grandes familles qui ont
composé le territoire des grandes
administrations
de l'ancien régime
les archives ont une vocation de
transparence administrative et d'accès à
des sources historiques large sont
collectés les archives ayant une valeur
importante notamment les actes produits
par les administrations on a un temps en
fait je dire de décantation des archives
dans les services qui correspondent à
leurs besoins administratifs et passé ce
besoin administratifs ont fait un
tricheur les archives et bien évidemment
en conserve qu'une toute petite part de
ce qui a été produit les archives les
plus demandés des documents liés à
l'histoire du territoire aux grandes
administrations à la justice ou encore
les fonds nécessaires à la généalogie
des archives accessibles à tous sur
présentation de la carte d'identité on
permet d'accéder plus facilement à
l'information c'est un petit peu
complexe ans de retrouver des documents
d'archivés ça se peut pas toujours
simplement et à partir de là
nous reçoit ses boîtes en saluer cruel
on peut les consulter directement sur
place les archives départementales
dispose d'une vingtaine de magasins
d'archivés spécialisés ici le climat le
volume d'humidité et la température sont
contrôlées les documents sont disposés
dans des boîtes de conservation
spécifiques et adaptées qui protège le
document de l'humidité d'une partie de
l'humilité puisque ça absorbe aussi
l'humilité du feu de l'eau s'il y avait
un incendie ou un désastre une
inondation la boîte en elle même mais
longtemps avant de devenir humide et
donc protège de documents maximum
document le plus ancien conservés aux
archives un diplôme de charles le chauve
datant du 9ème siècle c'est un document
de réemploi un parchemin de par un poids
qui avait été utilisé pour refaire une
couverture d'un ouvrage relié et donc
c'est au moment d'une restauration en
d'herlies l ouvrage qu'on a retrouvé ce
document extrêmement siens une
quarantaine de personnes travaillent sur
les fonds des archives ici le dépôt
arrive à ses limites
et maintenant que faire des vêtements
dont on se lasse et qu'on ne porte plus
ce qu'il faut les remodeler à son goût
peut-être c'est le pari en tout cas café
il ya trois ans la start-up d'alice
sadrin dans le val d'oise elle vous
permet d'apporter une touche
d'originalité à vos basiques son chiffre
d'affaires a triplé l'année dernière du
fait de la crise sanitaire romain ethuin
pour vyas 95 est allé voir sur place
lou diabolo ou encore gants de boxe
autant de motifs originaux apposé sur
vaut choisir sa base puis son motif
c'est tout le concept de my own création
à sa tête une besogneuse de 47 ans son
dernier best seller le costume de super
héros à personnaliser soi même on
choisit la taille donc je prends par
exemple du 5-6 ans donc je vais choisir
la forme que je vais m ensuite on va les
choisir la lettre de son prénom et là
vous avez votre costume un personnalisé
déjà soutenu par 14 actionnaires
l'entrepreneuse et ambitieuse pour en
arriver là elle a dû opérer un virage à
180° investisseurs sur les marchés
financiers cette maman de quatre enfants
a décidé de tout plaquer il y a trois
ans au profit de sa passion la couture
j'ai cette passion depuis dix ans au
début j'ai commencé avec mes enfants a
juste faire réparer à customiser un
petit peu pompe pour cacher pardon des
petits défauts et en fait on a fini par
personnalisée tout un tas petit chat
vaart et j'ai voulu à offrir ça aux gens
son chiffre d'affaires a triplé en 2020
grâce à la vente de masques
personnalisés aujourd'hui elle compte se
diversifier davantage à commencer par ce
kit pour bébés constitué par l'une des
deux couturières indépendante avec qui
elle collabore présente depuis le début
coline 28 ans est une véritable adeptes
du do it yourself
ce qui m'a séduite de base c'est
vraiment le concept
miss le côté de ne pas limiter la
création de chacun c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas obligé d'acheter un vêtement
qui a été créée tels que et on n'a pas
le choix finalement là on arrive sur des
vêtements où chacun peut amener sa
touche importés depuis le bangladesh
les vêtements sont entièrement réalisés
en coton bio de quoi augmenter encore un
peu plus la facture peu importe pour
marie celle qui arbore fièrement sa
chemise personnalisées et prêtes à
mettre le prix c'est vrai que de nos
jours pour trouver des vêtements qui
tiennent vide en plus de deux ans et qui
se déforme pas et qui ne décolère pas et
c'est ça peut être compliqué on ne
dépense pas plus au final puisque ça le
regarde sur le long terme pour continuer
de croître cette année
alice compte recruter deux couturières
supplémentaires elle a déjà mis au point
plusieurs prototypes de chemise a
personnalisé dès cet automne
et si la clé sanitaire a profité à
certains elle a surtout engendré de
nombreuses difficultés économiques en
moselle une entreprise spécialisée dans
l'événementiel est en pleine mutation
terminées les feux d'artifice place
désormais au spectacle 2.0 avec des
drones lumineux c'est pari que s'est
lancé un mosellan proposer des shows
avec des centaines de drones dansant
dans les airs un reportage de jean mi
longs pour moselle télévision regardez
c'est dans un petit hangar à
scy-chazelles que matthew gérant
d'entreprise dans l'événementiel
spécialisée dans les effets spéciaux en
tous genres prépare les spectacles de
demain une centaine de drones lumineux
programmé pour ne former qu'un et offrir
aux spectateurs un souvenir inoubliable
mais avant de décoller il faut tout
mettre en place
alors nous allons relier la station de
pilotage à l'ordinateur donc la station
qui se trouve ici
tout est piloté à partir de cet
ordinateur et vous avez différentes
antennes qui corresponde aux différents
protocoles de communication parce que le
drone communique avec la station et on
peut vérifier l'état du drone on a la
possibilité de ramener les drones si
jamais il n'a y avoir un problème
impossibilité de faire des coupures
moteur sur les drones avec un poids de
300 grammes et la liberté de choisir
entre plus de 16 millions de couleurs le
champ des possibles est presque infini
forme logo animaux la créativité est de
mise on peut laisser libre cours à notre
imagination aujourd'hui tout est
réalisable
bien entendu on ne pas dépasser les
contraintes techniques des machines et
la réglementation en vigueur si l'idée
d'un spectacle de drones trotter déjà
depuis longtemps dont la tête de mathieu
la crise sanitaire est venue accélérer
le processus alors qu'est ce que ça
donne un vrai coup de poker pour lui et
son père quand le prix d'un seul de
saison peut s'élever jusqu'à 2000 euros
on avait d'autres d'autres perspectives
sur sûr au niveau international qui
s'ouvrait pour nous est malheureusement
là qu'ovide nous arrêter dans notre élan
nous n'avons pratiquement plus de
travail
alors où je vous parle on avait des
dizaines de feux qui était programmé
pour le 13 14 juillet aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec plus qu'une même pas une
dizaine de feux donc c'est très
compliqué
justement cette arrivée de drones nous
va nous permettre de rebondir
c'est vraiment très jolie dans le grand
est matthew est pour le moment pionniers
de ces spectacles avant gardiste
également plus respectueux de
l'environnement avec la promesse de
vivre une expérience immersive où il n'y
a plus qu'à lever les yeux pour avoir la
tête dans les étoiles
[Musique]
et notre page consacrée au livre de
l'été air présent le grand jt des
territoires vous le savez vous propose
dans cette période estivale de découvrir
des auteurs et leurs romans et
d'emporter ainsi et des idées de lecture
en vacances nous sommes cette semaine en
duplex avec guillaume ghosn a bon jour
guillaume je vous êtes l'unique auteur
français d'une biographie d'un des
hommes politiques américains les plus
réputés au nom très connu kennedy mais
il ne s'agit pas bien sûr de john
fitzgerald kennedy mais de son frère
robert kennedy alors pourquoi avez vous
écrit une biographie sur robert kennedy
yangon à mieux connaître ce alice et
mieux comprendre cette période charnière
dans l'histoire des états unis ce qui on
sent beaucoup de témoignages sur verre
qu'ils y étaient le fait que ce soit
quelqu'un de très entier dans ses
qualités dans ce défaut très contrasté
très clair obscur est quelqu'un qui
était en perpétuel apprentissage actuels
mouvements
qui n'hésitait pas à se remettre en
question qui n'hésitait pas à changer
d'avis j'ai une anecdote à ce sujet qui
est à propos de la peine de mort aux
etats-unis quand il était mais à la
justice de son frère il était encore la
peine de mort et quand il est devenu
sénateur de new york qui ensuite
candidat présidentiel il s'est prononcé
en faveur en contre la peine de mort est
aujourd'hui se demander mais pourquoi
vous avez changé la vie et il a dit
parce que je n'avais pas lu camus avant
donc je pense pas que beaucoup de des
lieux aujourd'hui aurait une telle
capacité de nom ce manteau remise en
question sincère mais de deux réponses
aussi l'avis de robert kennedy était
intimement liée à celle de son frère au
fond notamment à cause de son assassinat
alors la vie de son frère ainsi nos
certitudes son assassinat roues en
revanche j'ai pas assez d'éléments pour
pouvoir me prononcer sur cette question
avec précision il faut savoir que l'avis
de robert kennedy était intégralement au
quasiment intégralement articulée autour
de son air autour de jack jusqu'au 22
novembre 1963 date à laquelle il est
donc assassiné à dallas et en leur
donnant ce sont 3 quand jfk disparaît il
se retrouve à la croisée de chemins il
se remet en question il va sortir
complètement transformé cette expérience
du fait de la disparition de son frère
quitté son sens son point focal son
point d'ancrage dans la vie de manière
générale quel homme ait et robert
kennedy
c'est un personnage absolument central
dans l'histoire contemporaine américaine
non seulement qui a beaucoup fait sonner
les années 50 60 70 aux états unis mais
qui en plus de ça continue d'avoir une
influence énorme comme beaucoup de
géants de mythe politique américain des
années 60 aujourd'hui à tel point que
d'ailleurs je byden arbore un bus de
robert kelly dans son bureau de bureau
ovale à washington depuis qu'il a
encaissé de notre hub et c'est
exactement ce dont je me suis rendu
compte en banque étant si robert kennedy
pour préparer ce livre notamment après
le cinquantenaire de l'assassinât de jfk
dallas beaucoup de livres et de
documentaires et de films étaient sortis
et j'avais m'étais rendu compte que
robert kennedy était un peu l'élément
clé en fait guillaume konaré vous
d'autres projets d'écriture une autre
biographie par exemple d'un homme
politique américain locale alors oui
j'ai d'autres projets d'écriture
toujours sur les états unis beaucoup
articulée autour donné 60 qui pour moi
une période fantastique et un complément
bouillonnante culturelles musicales
politique sociétal pour sa biographie
sur berck il dit j'ai rencontré john
lewis l'ancien cours de la semaine qui
est décédé voici un peu plus d'une année
maintenant et ce héros de droits
civiques proche de martin luther king
proche de robert kennedy qui a connu gfk
cas comme une idole johnson cette
rencontre a beaucoup touché il était
notamment le leader de la marge de
seulement 65
c'est un projet qui me tient à coeur et
que j'aimerais pouvoir faire aboutir ce
il si j'arrive à prendre un peu plus de
temps pour écrire du évidemment d'autres
projets sur les états unis sur sur
l'écriture bon je serais heureux d'en
parler quand il dit quand il se
concrétiseront merci google d'avoir été
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires
bonne chance pour vos nouveaux projets
bonnes vacances et puis pour ceux qui
veulent en savoir plus sur robert
kennedy votre ouvrage est disponible aux
éditions fayard après la lecture des
idées de sorties en ce mois d'août le no
tourisme connaissez-vous cette
découverte des vins des caves des
exploitants directement sur leur domaine
cette activité était encore mal perçus
par les grands crus il y a peu de temps
mais les choses évoluent les propriétés
viticoles sont nombreuses désormais à
promouvoir cette offre décryptage de
cette tendance avec franck hoareau de la
rédaction de tv la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest environ
il ya quelques années l'offre
oenotouristique des cru classé 1855 se
limiter à une visite de la propriété sur
rendez vous suivi d'une dégustation de
vins depuis cette offre s'est largement
étayée structurer le château marquis de
terme à margaux s'est lancé dans le lot
tourisme il ya huit ans maintenant cette
propriété propose des locations de
salles pour des mariages ou des
séminaires de la location de vélo pour
parcourir son vignoble des brunchs le
week-end dans quelques jours un
restaurant bistronomique situé en plein
coeur de ce château va ouvrir ses portes
pour sandrine chanfreau directrice du
pôle tourisme de ce château cette
diversification de l'offre est essentiel
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a des cibles
très variés on peut avoir très bien des
cibles si on reste sur la partie
touristique de l'étranger mais aussi une
population locale et aussi du
périphérique à des bordelais donc il
faut vraiment travailler les offres de
plus en plus adapté pour pouvoir attirer
ces publics très différents le château
giscours a compris bien longtemps que
cette diversification d'activité est
essentielle ici l'accueil du public et
l'hospitalité qu'on lui accorde ne sont
pas des vains mots ils sont même
stratégique pour l'image de la propriété
qui sera véhiculée par les visiteurs
l'idée est d'en faire des ambassadeurs
si vous réussissez à bien accueillir
pendant un mariage bien vous avez des
ambassadeurs avis donc on va un peu plus
loin que le transit traditionnels visite
dégustation bien sûr qu'on le propose
mais on crée un échange parce que c'est
très important que le visiteur puisse
s'exprimer et créer cet échange mais pas
que écoutez le château giscours organise
des concerts propose à ses visiteurs des
paniers pique nique à déguster dans son
parc organise des dîners de gala cette
propriété a même recruté un chef de
cuisine à temps complet le point d'orgue
de l'activité de touristique de giscours
étant son jumping équestre organisée en
plein air cinq cent cinquante cavaliers
sein les visiteurs sont attendus ici
début juillet le lot torisme est devenue
une entreprise dans l'entreprise pour
s'est cru classé 1855 leur offre à même
d'ailleurs été reconnue par
l'organisation mondiale du tourisme à la
fin de l'année de lui va là la démarche
des châteaux étant de plus en plus forte
et dynamique il nous fallait trouver des
acteurs internationaux comme le les vins
seront vendus dans le monde entier on a
des gens qui équipe qui peuvent
apprécier venir visiter bordeaux et
veiller à visiter si cru classé 1855 du
monde entier donc il fallait trouver des
acteurs mondiaux
longtemps considérée comme annexe parler
cru classé 1855 lot tourisme est
aujourd'hui une activité à part entière
un rémunératrice pour en fonction des
années elle peut peser jusqu'à 10% du
chiffre d'affaires de ses châteaux sur
les 88 cru classé du médoc et du
sauternais 40 d'entre eux ont
complètement professionnaliser leur
offre oenotouristique
doremi là où tout a commencé
plus qu'une phrase de lancement c'est
désormais le thème d'un nouveau parcours
de visite de la maison natale de jeanne
d'arc située dans les vosges réalisé
l'an passé à l'occasion du bicentenaire
de son ouverture au public la rénovation
s'est matérialisée par la réhabilitation
du centre d'interprétation sur place
découverte avec la rédaction de vos jeux
télévision regarde
dont rémy là où tout a commencé
changement de créneau pour le nouveau
parcours de visite de la maison natale
de jeanne d'arc autrefois centrée sur
ses combats loin des vosges le site a
tenu à réaffirmer l'importance du
département dans la vie de l'héroïne
mais pas question de toucher à la
bâtisse classée monument historique
depuis 1840 la réhabilitation est donc
passé par la modernisation du centre
d'interprétation voisin le précédent au
centre avait été réalisée en 1999 donc
c'est vrai qu'il avait au niveau de la
muséographie il racontait alors rebond
une histoire de l'époque de jeanne d'arc
mais par des outils d'aujourd'hui donc
on a souhaité en fait moderniser
complètement cette présentation la
rendre plus interactif aussi en faisant
appel aux luttes immédiat et puis des
manipulations des questions allez dans
quelque chose de plus dynamique plus
vivant inauguré en septembre 2020 à
l'occasion du bicentenaire de
l'ouverture du site au public ainsi
qu'aux s'entend de la canonisation de
jeanne d'arc le nouveau parcours n'avait
pas pu bénéficier d'une grande
fréquentation ce mercredi était donc
l'occasion de le présenter
officiellement après sa réouverture le
19 mai dernier une nouvelle formule avec
pour axe principal l'enfance de celle
que l'on surnomme la pucelle aurait mis
un lieu incontournable des compensations
d'arc parce que c'est le lieu d'achat où
elle a vécu le plus année de sa courte
vie elle a quand même passé 17 années
donc a dormi sur les 19
de son existence et puis c'est le lieu
où elle est née où elle a grandi où il
s'est façonné et qui conditionne et
finalement beaucoup de choses de soin de
son épopée et dès l'âge de 7 ans jeanne
d'arc a vu le village voisin de max et
son muscle brûlé donc ça ça l'a marqué
et donc je crois que cette existence que
l'amener à doremi lui a fait prendre
conscience effectivement des réalités de
son époque
carté écrans interactifs tenue et
armures d'époque tous les visiteurs
peuvent désormais se rendre sur le site
afin de profiter de l'accès gratuit à la
visite jusqu'au 30 juin inclus parmi les
nouveautés les plus probantes la mise en
place d'un parcours et d'un livret jeu
pour les enfants chacun pourra donc
désormais arpenter les couloirs du
centre à travers des différentes
thématiques et se faire leur propre avis
sur la plus célèbre des dons rémoise
jeanne d'arc est effectivement toujours
très populaire elle intéresse beaucoup
les gens pourquoi bien parce que c'est
quand même un destin c'est exceptionnel
de cette jeune fille qui à 17 ans se
sont investis de cette mission qui
changent véritablement le cours des
choses en faisant en libérant orléans et
en fezensac ray charles vii et puis
aussi à cause des conditions de vent
très long procès un procès inique et
politiques de tous ses points de vue
finalement jeanne d'arc apparaît comme
une sorte d'héroïne et qu'on ne peut pas
tellement contesté en fait contrairement
à d'autres personnages vous parlais de
napoléon récemment cas une face plus
sombre jeanne d'arc est entièrement
lumineuse en quelque sorte une facette
que le département des vosges aura eu à
coeur de mettre en avant avec ces
changements et le programme est loin
d'être terminée dès le 19 juin jusqu'à
la fin de la saison en décembre les
activités reconstitution conférences et
ateliers s'enchaîneront toutes les
semaines avec notamment le spectacle des
cendres de jeanne programmé fin juillet
une vue imprenable sur lorient c'est ce
qu'offre la tour de la découverte ce
monument emblématique de la ville est
ouvert au public tout l'été l'occasion
de voir son tout nouveau dôme et la
signalisation maritime du 19e siècle
clara jestin a grimpé les 216 marche
pour la rédaction de tébéo et de tv sud
l'échelle du groupe le télégramme sur
place un tour de clé 2 116 marches à
monter pour arriver au sommet de la tour
de la dégoût art et profiter de cette
vue à 360° sur la rade de lorient c'est
l'un des points l'un des points les plus
hauts qui va faire écho par exemple au
toit de la base de sous marins mais qui
ici est vraiment en choeur de sur le
coeur historique de lorient qui permet
de découvrir d'abord cet enclos du port
de la compagnie des indes la première
ville qui se développe au 19e siècle et
la ville actuelle ok mais du 20e du 21e
siècle du haut de ses 38 mètres la dame
de pierre surplombe la rade de belle-ile
jusqu au bénin et si elle ressemble à un
phare ce n'était pas son rôle au milieu
du xviiie siècle tour de guet pour la
compagnie des indes qui veillait au
retour des bateaux d'orient qui
apportait avec eux leur marchandise
précieuse mais surtout qui a été associé
à l'observatoire de marine qu'il était
installé dans les moulins situés à ses
pieds observatoire de marine reliés à la
boule horaires que l'on voit derrière
moi et qui donnait aux marins chaque
jour leur astronomiques pour leur
permettre de se référer dans leur
navigation en mer sur les océans
cette boule horaires et la dernière
encore en fonctions en france fermé au
public depuis 2018 la tour de la
découverte s'est refait une petite
beauté c'est un chantier de longue
haleine
l'accent à d'abord été mis sur la
coupole et le signal horaire nous nous
intéressons maintenant forcément à
l'intérieur pour un confort de visite la
question de la valorisation de
l'ensemble de la colline du faouëdic se
pose aussi aller il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire pour ce beau patrimoine 1
dès le samedi 12 juin des visiteurs
pourront à nouveau grimper tout en haut
et découvrir le panorama de quoi avoir
un peu le tournis
à les partants à présent dans la loire
dans le village de saint-just-la-pendue
cette commune a une particularité le
clocher de son église abrite un
réservoir qui alimente une partie de la
population et d'élise alentours en eau
potable et la légende dit que cette eau
est bénite explications de céline
ersilia pour tl7 la télévision de la
loire
en haut du village de saint jules a
pondu coule une eau fraîche et
cristalline toute la nuit une eau
précieuse pour les 1684 habitants et
pour cause
[Musique]
à
elle arrive directement du clocher de
l'église juste au dessus du coeur à 14
mètres de haut un réservoir de 50 mètres
cubes y est installé depuis 1951 et il
n'a pas fallu très longtemps pour que le
lieu imprègne cette réserve d'eau
potable nous les élus ont bu on dit très
souvent qu'à cinq vendues on boit de
l'eau bénite cateau elle est très bonne
c'est de l'eau que l'on consomme toute
l'année et qui est très agréable à boire
elle nous la consommons tous les joueurs
à table et c'est une eau qui arrive à
nous faire quelques centenaires sont nos
communes l'eau de saint-just-la-pendue
auraient-elles quelques vertus dans le
village tout le monde profite de cette
eau consacré et on s'amuse même de cette
petite particularité c'est bien de
profiter de l'eau bénite sur les cheveux
on va dire que ça les rend brillant on a
le privilège de boire une eau bénite
toute l'année voilà ça vous fait quelque
chose vous vous sentez des bienfaits aux
non pas ce point là c'est la salle
occasions j'aurais de l'eau bénite parce
que l'eau bénite je m'en sers jamais
si jamais sur mes cheveux ce sera une
bonne chose
le paradis aujourd'hui les habitants ne
font plus qu'à de cette eau provenant de
leur église ils s'intéressent plus à la
qualité gustative de cette source qui
sans être converties certains pourraient
même lui trouver un petit goût de
paradis
direction la corse pour terminer ce
journal où il est possible de monter à
cheval pour faire du tourisme une idée
originale pour porter un autre regard
sur les richesses de l'île et notamment
sur le fameux déserts de la grille at
une balade qui vous conduit dans les
plus beaux endroits de la région
regardez ces images magnifiques de nos
partenaires sur place le coucher du
soleil y est lui aussi extraordinaire
les détails au micro de viata n'est pas
aisé même des cavaliers corse qui tourne
parfois dans différents centres
équestres pour faire des balades
certains beaucoup ont dit mais pour une
balade pour eux c'est la plus belle
parce qu'on peut voir de très beaux
paysages dès le moment qu'on fait des
randonnées de plusieurs jours évidemment
il ya des tas de micro régions ou des
paysages sont magnifiques mer montagne
mer pour une seule balade de deux heures
qui est accessible pour un débutant même
quelqu'un qui ait jamais monté assez oui
avec le coucher de soleil pour le soir
voilà de bien belles images pour
conclure cette édition c'est la fin de
ce grand jt des territoires merci de
l'avoir suivi sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales de la tnt sur tv5 monde a
très vite pour une nouvelle édition de
ce tour complet de l'actualité estivale
de nos territoires au revoir à tous
[Musique]